do you know I think everything is my
fault like all of it everybody prepared
finds their opportunity
do you really think that you're the
greatest of all time and you can do it
and that also you're a piece of and
nobody cares when you're gone Juanes or
get a mentor what's up believe nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so today let's
learn from one of the best Gary Vee and
how successful people think mentor me
Gary also if you want to know what Gary
and other successful entrepreneurs have
to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description below
the reason people don't put themselves
in a position to fail the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one don't live in the middle the number
one mistake that people are making in
life today and it's and it's just so
unbelievably obvious is they're living
life in the middle you know 99.9% of the
people that watch or listen to this
content are living in the middle there
they're hedging and making excuses and
justifying why they are not 100% happy
it's because like every other person out
there besides a few select people they
are living in this middle ground and I
just say the middle and when I think
about how you win in business and
entrepreneurship but most of all in life
it's by understanding the macro and
micro opportunities and executions if
you really understand how to break
through how to be in that zone how to
really really really win the game it
comes down to a strategy that looks like
this are you balancing your ego with
your humility are you balancing your ego
with your humility
do you Iike lis think that you're the
greatest of all time and you can do it
and that also you're a piece of [ __ ] and
nobody cares when you're gone
rule number two ignore the noise I think
the biggest vulnerability you've got is
you actually value somebody's opinion
more than you value your own but the
reason I've been able to always do my
thing is when I was 24 and people were
like oh you work at your dad's liquor
store like I heard that it's like a chip
on my shoulder you know I loved it I was
like cool keep sleeping on me you know
like I'm glad you're on Wall Street
making a hundred thousand buying BMWs
and dumb jewelry I'll see you in 30
years you understand like to me the way
you win is you realize you can't hear
nobody not your parents I mean listen
you got to listen to coach and all that
I get it but at the end of the day my
guy yourself you got to get real real
quiet up here
I can't hear anything you go look at my
Instagram right now my first post up
something first hundred replies in one
second your Jesus you walk up water
you're the best you're the all-time
can't hear him the next hundred you're a
piece of your foolish you're a snake oil
salesman can't hear him I'm in my own
mind doing my own thing and that comes
with self-esteem everybody's trying to
keep up with the Joneses I'm not worried
about you being on the in the Hamptons
on a blow-up Swan
I'm not worried about you renting out
cash from the bank and putting it to
your ear I'm not worrying you jumped a
fence and took a photo in front of a
private plane what do you think these
people are doing they're posing patients
long game you know what's amazing about
being an entrepreneur we get to play
forever right I'm gonna be working when
I'm 96 trying to find my next hustle
rule number three take on responsibility
the reason I say the thing that if
there's anybody that ever looked like
you that made it then there's no excuse
is cuz I believe it you know it's really
hard here in our argument and that your
friend tells you that's great Gary but
both my parents were alcoholics and that
really me up right now you're on the
defense that's a good first punch by
them am i cool we don't need to use me
if anybody has ever been successful that
had two alcoholic parents which by the
way I know of three well then now what's
your Excuse Karen we are just so
interested in blaming everybody else and
excuses cuz we don't want to take on
responsibility and some were a long time
ago I went completely I only take I do
you know I think everything is my fault
like all of it like I think it's weirdly
cloudy outside right now and not nice
out my fault
like his scar my fault
like I just default into my fault and
everybody tries to do everything else
the other way and let me tell you how
good life becomes when you take on
responsibility it gets real good uh some
of you and there's a lot of you that
follow me you know why I keep bringing
up the last scene of eight mile the
Eminem movie how many people have seen
that movie great
the last scene they go into the battle
he makes fun of himself the whole time
because it leaves the other person with
nothing the leverage is in being
accountable of everything the leverage
is exposing your weaknesses I proudly
talk about passing on uber twice being a
DNF student
you know I proudly talk about my
shortcomings right I can't wait for more
bad things to happen I mean it because I
will talk about them because what you're
so imperfect Q rule number four be
prepared opportunity meets preparation
that's something a lot of people talk
about I'll tell you what I believe in I
believe that there's so much opportunity
at all times that it's actually
preparation everybody prepared finds
their opportunity yeah so so sure I
believe in it but here's what I actually
believe in opportunity is abundant
mm-hmm we live in a world that has
unlimited opportunity especially if
you're willing to look for it hmm
looking for it is predicated on the fact
that you put in the work you put in the
work because you knew that you were
gonna go look for it
so I believe in preparation preparation
preparation because I just believe that
opportunity is almost like oxygen it's
everywhere
always and some opportunities are bigger
than others but preparation man people
don't do people convince themselves
before they start that the world is
unjust or they can't their stings are up
they complain they do well they say no
before they say yes and of course look
if you say no it's already over like a
litter if you wake up and say it's not
gonna happen for me it's already over
you you might as well not try rule
number five just do your asking a
different question you're asking when is
the time to jump in the pool when is the
time to kiss the boy when's the time you
know to get married you know you're
talking about like when's the time to
take the training wheels off the bike
you know when the time to live your life
that that's probably why I made content
the answer is I don't know nobody knows
there's no right answer there's that
moment in time
this is why produce content everyday if
you might be watching my content every
day and it might be this conversation
with us in the vlog that is you know
it's very meta this might have been the
one this might have been the one on this
day because of a conversation you had
last night because of the weather
outside because of a news headline
because of the patterns of how the for
Instagram posts came in your feed it
might just be the time you finally do
what you're supposed to do and I think a
lot of people think of it as like quit
your job and go do your journey right
things you're thinking about others I
think of it a little bit different
sometimes it's that's exactly right
sometimes it's like mm-hmm I've been
doing this nightlife and t-shirt thing
for seven years well why don't I go work
for something smart for a year reset why
don't I go travel
why don't I sell my home that I don't
use 90% of take that money get an
apartment and then do something with
that money so to me it's not just like
the fancy sizzle of like now jump into
the rest of your life it's also like
it's also like awed it understand what
you need break up with that person marry
that person you know you know start your
career go back to corporate for an hour
okay a year or two to reset like you
know
just do it's the indecisiveness decision
it's the indecisiveness that is the
poison because you can always undo the
biggest thing about doing is the undoing
that people don't see I'm always like
okay good and then like if you fail go
back if people don't want the Scarlet
Letter they don't want the judgment this
is why you have to tune everything out
because if you go and judge start your
t-shirt brand or your pin brand or your
video blog and it fails if you just
think you can go back to it well that
sounds cool
but if you feel like oh but then
everybody's got a clown on me and see
they say like then you're if you're if
you're pessimistic moms and be like see
I told you you could never do it if you
can't get over that then you stuck rule
number six look for positivity you find
what you're looking for I've been giving
a lot of thought to kind of just
watching what I'm seeing out there in
the social digital ecosystem and very
honestly just real life and I'm watching
so many people over the last two to
three years look for negativity look for
something that's wrong find where people
disagree with them fight look for what
was me downside the half glass empty and
then I go to a Twitter search or look
around the world and I find ridiculously
beautiful things every day every day
thousands of kind acts randomly by
people all people that I have
conversations with who see the
opportunities whether it's in business
like voice and AR or crypt or whatever
it may be just this amazingly
interesting thing that I feel the
majority of you are looking for the
wrong while there's a plenty of wrong
and plenty of right in the world
it comes down to one very simple thing
what are you choosing to look for
because I promise you if you right now
and I'm making this video for one reason
24 hours of trying to find the good
somebody saves a kid somebody opens the
door somebody does a nice thing for you
bit somebody says thank you
24 hours of looking for positivity could
change your life honestly making this
for one person's one one person watches
this video chooses to do 24 hours of
looking for good
instead of looking for bad and their
game changes d-roc heard somebody at a
convenience store saying mom you're
always so negative you're always so
negative I am blown away by the fact
that life gets real simple if you break
down into this are you looking for the
negative this sucks this government
sucks this person sucks this is or
you're looking for the positive she's
nice that's remarkable I've got this
opportunity you choose what you're
looking for because what you look for
you find that's how life works and rule
number seven the last one before a very
special bonus clip is work hard and
smart how much time do you spend a month
you said those four things how much time
do you actually spend on it in a day
zero
sometimes I assume in a week how much do
you spend two hours great now is the
most important part of this meeting
how many hours do you sleep at night
great so I love the way you said it I
have to have seven so if I wanted to say
go to six so that you pick up five
you're gonna say to me Gary I have to
have seven right now let's go somewhere
else I have to know what you're doing
the other 17 hours I would bet the house
that we can find an hour every day I'm
guaranteeing because you might be
working all 17 hours but you might not
be working on something smarter than
spending an hour a day on the thing that
you're talking about do you understand
that's I mean look that's the answer the
answer is time you know people talk
about working hard and working smart the
answer is only both
you have to work hard and smart based on
your ambition if you want to build a
business for yourself that is like a 1%
life most people understand what
building a business for yourself is it's
very special it's very special trying to
build a business for yourself
everybody's doing now pulling it off
trying to play basketball everybody can
try being an NBA player trying to be a
rapper or a singer
everybody's doing pulling it off trying
to be a footballer and actress got it
so you're trying great pulling it off is
hard it takes everything time and smarts
you need seven I'm glad you said it that
way because this makes this piece of
content more valuable
it's the 17 other Alice
I'll give an example a lot of people
drive to work for 45 minutes if they
took a bus for an hour and 15 minutes
they would save money and get more work
done
but do you have the humility to take the
bus forces driving your car
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Gary on how to add value that I
think you're really gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
taking action and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what do
you need to just do number two what
noise do you need to ignore and number
three what does working hard and smart
look like to you
because this is so see anything you know
your secrets away at the same time I
mean because doing the right thing is
the right thing
karma is practical you know I heard
somebody rant earlier right that's like
hey when I win I don't think it's coming
out of you the guy that closed I
couldn't know who was on stage but I
believe in that right because I love the
idea of 85 people here going and
listening to me winning I didn't make
anything for it but it then becomes
brand if she goes down and listens and
then two years later she's having dinner
with a friend and she's talking about
what happened to her life that friend
might be the CEO of GE you know I'm
playing with the biggest brands in the
world I'm not trying to monetize my
audience I'm trying to like just bring
the most value in the world and let that
lift all my other opportunities so I
think I think giving away your best
secrets is the greatest strategy for two
reasons karma is practical and leads to
more business but here's the secret and
it's even funnier 99% of these people
are not going to do anything about it
the somewhere about five or six years
ago I realize this fact holy people
aren't going to do anything with this so
it like there's still gonna be plenty
for me and I'm gonna be the most lovable
guy ever I love this so you know
wherever you are on Instagram and
Facebook made for PR did you really
think that was a good idea I know bro I
honestly think that that was one of like
the worst moves I've ever seen because
[Applause]
I'm not trying to razz you either I am
talking I'm trying to give you love I
love the passion to win the problem is
you tried to close on the first move you
brought them no value and you asked them
to bring you value like you gave like I
will stand up here and give a [ __ ] load
of value and never mention one time for
any of them to follow me and a lot more
of them will follow me then they're
gonna follow that [ __ ] move that you
just did
I get it I get it but this was back to
the question that just happened this is
why I want you to win that move is
always gonna lose you can't go tonight
when you go out in Vegas and you see a
pretty girl at the bar you can't go up
to her and the opening move is like
here's my key let's go [ __ ] but but
that's what you just did let them hold
it but that's what you just did to this
audience with business
if you want more garyvee check at the
top 50 rules for success video I made on
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
my ability to only be comfortable in
massive chaos has been my biggest asset
as an entrepreneur like I would never
take a note